recuerda que para averiguar el lugar en
el que un rayo bidimensional se
intersecta con un segmento lineal
empezamos por introducir primero un
sistema de coordenadas una vez que
tenemos nuestro sistema de coordenadas
podemos escribir nuestra línea ave en la
forma pendiente intersección
ya que en este ejemplo tiene las
coordenadas 32 y ve las coordenadas 41
la forma pendiente intersección de ave
es que equivale a menos 13 x + 11 de
manera similar si le asignó a peu las
coordenadas 2 un medio entonces la forma
pendiente intersección del rayo cp es
que equivale a un cuarto de x
el punto y que buscamos está en ambas
líneas por lo tanto si sube x e y sub
representa las coordenadas de y entonces
y sub que es igual a menos 3 y sube x +
11 porque está en ave e hizo que es
igual a un cuarto de iu sube x porque
está en el rayo cp
resolver estas dos ecuaciones para las
dos incógnitas nos da las coordenadas y
sube x e y sub
usar la forma pendiente intersección del
rayo funciona en 2d y es algo
relativamente sencillo de entender pero
hay un problema cuando generalizamos el
concepto en tres dimensiones el problema
es que en tres dimensiones el rayo no
tiene una forma pendiente intersección
entonces tendremos que desechar esta
representación de nuestro rayo en
preparación para el racing en tres
dimensiones para representar nuestro
rayo cp usaremos algo llamado función
paramétrica lo que estoy a punto de
escribir se ve algo extraño al principio
pero ten paciencia conmigo estas
funciones empiezan a convertirse en algo
familiar con la práctica representaré me
rayó con una nueva función r dt que es
un promedio ponderado de s&p donde t es
el peso
en particular escribiré rdc como uno
de porsche master por p observa lo que
pasa cuando te es igual a cero
1 - t es simplemente uno por lo tanto r
de 0 s y cuando te es igual a 1 r de uno
es igual a p
esto resulta muy práctico porque puedo
volver a etiquetar hace como r de 0 y
puedo volver a etiquetar a p como r de
1era de un medio que daría exactamente a
la mitad de la distancia entre c y p
los valores de t mayores que 1 hacen
referencia a puntos en el rayo fuera de
la escena más allá de p
antes de continuar práctica este tipo de
función paramétrica en el siguiente
ejercicio